so here we are at summer wind & Land
O'Lakes Wisconsin really pretty area
hoping to get this rebuilt in the near
future
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to episode
54 of the 13 o'clock podcast we have
something of a special edition for you
guys today as regular listeners know we
don't have a lot of guests on the show
and when we do have them it's always
someone who were a big fan of whose work
we admire a lot so today is one of those
special occasions when we actually have
a guest I'll tell you all about it in
just a few minutes but first we have to
do our regular beginning of the show
housekeeping first of all please don't
forget to go subscribe to our sister
list channel 13 o'clock in minutes there
are currently 13 list videos of cool
creepy [ __ ] on there for your viewing
enjoyment and I will be putting more of
them up very soon they take a long time
to do so don't rush me you know also if
you haven't seen them yet we have our
fun movie retrospectives in their own
little playlist on the main 13 o'clock
channel as of this recording there are
four up and our latest one is going to
be escape from New York which will
either be up by the time this episode
comes out or will be up a day or two
after it so keep an eye out for that you
guys seem to be enjoying these we're
really having a good time doing them and
we have a humongous list of movies that
we want to feature in the future so
hopefully we'll be doing many more of
them in the weeks and months to come
also if you haven't done so kindly check
out my paranormal books including my
latest one the unseen hand a new
exploration of poltergeist phenomena and
for those of you who are into true crime
please sit tight because my very newest
book the faceless villain a collection
of the eeriest unsolved murders of the
20th century vol 1 should be out before
Halloween hopefully so please keep an
eye out for that as well we also have a
couple more true crime topics coming up
on this show as well that some viewers
have recommended like the wine bill
chicken coop murders and a couple other
ones maybe a Liesl and the corpse
Wood Manor murders things of that nature
so we're gonna be doing those before the
end of the year probably so keep your
ears peeled for that also and in October
remember that Tom and I will be
panelists at the spooky Empire horror
convention in Orlando Florida
on October 27th 28th and 29th it'll be
at the Orange County Convention Center
we will be running the sick and twisted
panel that's on Friday night and will be
on several other panels over the course
of the whole weekend and there's a lot
of really cool topics there's a lot of
really cool guests that are coming and
we'll be having a lot of fun discussions
so come out and check that out and we'll
also be doing meeting and mingling with
the public and I'll have a bunch of my
books that you guys can buy and I will
sign them and take pictures with you and
whatever so you can come out and see us
if you were in the Orlando area on the
weekend before Halloween also if you
missed it Tom and I were guests on the
conspiratorial podcast with Adam Sain it
was episode 177 we talked about
everything from poltergeist to Star Wars
to necrophilia that was really fun and a
good time was had by all it was a very
funny show if we do say so ourselves so
go to Cannes paranormal comm and do a
search and find it it's very easy to
find or just you know search
conspiratorial podcast and it'll come up
it was a very recent episode so go check
that out as well and please don't forget
to support us on patreon get some fun
exclusive stuff like extra quasi
episodes extra blog posts and movie
reviews various other entertaining
things that we put up there every now
and then we recently had our first
Google hangout there will be another one
on the last weekend of September for all
$10 and up patrons who want to
participate and I usually send
invitations out like a week to a few
days before so you know if you have a
preference about time or day or whatever
for the $20 Knut patrons we are going to
start sending out some free swag
probably the first package will be maybe
some free books bookmarks that kind of
fun stuff maybe some postcard stuff so
those should
start mailing out about the middle of
September like September 15th I'm gonna
try and start mailing those out so if
you're a $20 and up patron please keep
an eye out for that now let's get on
with the show okay now if you guys
remember I don't know how you could have
forgotten but in case you did back on
episode 39 of 13 o'clock we did a
discussion slash review of the episode
of a haunting that was called the
haunting of summer wind and it was our
winner of one of our favorite episodes
of the show and it was also the one that
spawned our famous and beloved and much
repeated sound clip you know the one I'm
talking about
there it is well not long after the
episode aired we were able to make
contact with Craig Mehring who not only
grew up in Wisconsin right near the
Summerwind mansion and hung out there
and when he was in high school when the
mentioned before the mansion burned down
in the 80s but he also later founded the
paranormal investigation team known as
the Fox Valley ghost hunters he's
written a book called Wisconsin's most
haunted and has another volume of that
coming out very soon and he is also
helping the current owners of the
property where the ruins of summer winds
stand to raise the funds to completely
restore the mansion to its former glory
which would actually be really awesome
so I'm happy to say we finally got
around to interviewing him for this show
and without further ado we present our
discussion with Craig Nehring about the
legend and the hopeful future
restoration of summer wind enjoy okay we
have Craig nari on the line he's from
the Fox Valley ghost hunters and he's
doing this summer wind restoration
Society
how you doing Craig thanks very much for
being on the show we've been wanting to
have you on the show for a while we've
been you know we've gone back and forth
for a few months now and we finally yeah
I guess your agent contacted us is your
age Joshua yeah we call my publicist he
kind of gets us a lot of our radio shows
and different things
okay cool what shows have you been on
coast to coast
fade to black with Jimmy Church a bunch
of other ones actually I was on
Jason Hawes show I think it's beyond
reality yeah okay yeah yeah all those
are really good shows yeah I heard you
I'm fade to black actually yeah like
that one that was like two hours it was
a long one
yes Jimmy Church yeah yeah okay so
you're gonna restore summer wind we're
hoping to UM it's just a matter of
getting the funds to restore it back to
the original look that it looked on the
outside you know the inside is gonna
have to be brought up to the codes to
the day today's standards of courts yeah
that was my favorite episode on the
haunting the haunting a summer wood
episode really cool now eventually that
house burned down to the foundations
there's nothing left except the
foundations right yeah just the two tall
chimneys which are kind of iconic to
summer wind everybody kind of knows the
place you know we see a picture the
minute they see the pictures of the two
chimneys are at all--that's summer wind
yeah how accurate do you think that
episode was truthfully I don't believe
it's a hundred percent accurate I've you
know I've talked to the local police the
authorities in the area people that used
to be on the police department back in
the day fire department they said there
were ever never any cars that started on
fire there's no record of that so and I
know in the book or in maybe in the
haunting itself too they were talking
about cars that would mysteriously start
on the fire yeah that's right because I
don't I don't remember if it was on the
episode but a couple of the breakdowns
that I was reading of the Summerwind
case online they did say that Arnold
Hinshaw who was you know the father of
the family that moved in there in the
70s that said that he went out to go to
work in his house caught him on fire
you listened to the show that we did on
summer wind oh yeah that was back that
was episode 39 absolutely 39 I was
always had the impression under the
impression just by analyzing the the
haunting episode I always kind of felt
that ginger and Shawn Arnold and Shaw
that that the original people involved
in this story I thought that maybe their
story was the closest to the truth yeah
thank um since a Raymond bond Bober you
know the guy that was there the popcorn
bender yeah that suppose we had the cars
start on fire and stuff and created the
book the Carver effect based off the
hauntings and she never even lived in
the house you know ever yeah stayed on
the property but never actually lived in
the house just his parents had and like
you said I believe they're the ones that
have more the accurate account to what
had happened where I think Graham and
Vaughn Bober made some money off the
books and added some extra things too I
mean you're gonna almost have to add
something I could to create it and make
it interesting yes he gotten stuff as
soon as he got involved in this case all
of a sudden it became the story became
very mythical and quality yep definitely
even with the dreams of him saying he
had a dream of a English explorer or
England British explorer Jonathan Carver
finding or having a deed to one third of
northern Wisconsin supposedly being
buried in the foundation and this was
just a dream you know no you got all
these people even to to this day going
up there and trying to break apart the
foundation what's left to look for a
deed that probably doesn't exist yeah I
mean that deed would have been written
120 years before the house is built yep
and I read the travels the journeys of
Jonathan Carver I went through his
journeys and if you read the journeys of
Jonathan Carver he never made it that
far north to where the summer one
property was so there wouldn't be
anything buried anywhere on that
foundation maybe somewhere else there's
also rumors that the deed was found from
Jonathan Carver and isn'ta isn't any
museum up in England somewhere so yeah I
mean Jonathan Carver was a real guy it's
just the whole you know the whole thing
about Raymond Bober life saying that he
was either hypnotized or had dreams that
he was showing him where the deed was
and yeah it sounded far-fetched and all
this other stuff but now you are from
Wisconsin yes
so was it kind of summer wind that got
you interested in the paranormal like
hearing about summer wind cuz it was
quite a famous haunted house even from
back in the day right yeah I used to go
there
is when I I've lived up I'm not only a
short 45 minutes from the mansion maybe
even less than that and then we used to
go there and as you know kids to party
up there when we were in high school so
we used to see stuff that we couldn't
explain at the time there's no
electricity in there and lights would go
on
um just weird stuff that would happen so
I kind of got interested in paranormal
back then but of course back then you
know we're kids or you know we have a
lot more more important thing to do than
you know go go something or start a
paranormal team and then all the ghosts
and the show's started popping up her
own mm late 90s and I thought hey you
know I'd be awesome to have a team so I
started my team around that time when
all the children on TV yeah you know
we've actually mentioned before that the
paranormal back in the 80s in the 70s
when we were growing up was a lot
different than it is now there weren't a
bunch of shows no nothing not much at
all if I recall just you know the normal
or TV shows yeah I think the best thing
we had was what in search of yeah normal
and then every now and then you get a
like a supernatural story on like
unsolved mysteries or something yeah
Twilight Zone or something yeah that was
usually murders but sometimes it was
yeah I think the best thing we had up
until up until recently really was
probably our bail show so you actually
you actually saw this mansion when it
was standing before it burned down or
burned down you'd go into it yep 85 it
didn't burn down to father's day in 1988
and I was in high school during 85 to 88
so my father used to know the owner that
live next door to the summerwine mansion
used to tell us stories about it all the
time now
it wasn't really lightning to burn down
and somebody don't burn it down anything
I've actually found a newspaper clipping
for two weeks prior to when lightning
supposedly struck the mansion and it
stated that they wanted the town wanted
to raise the mansion because too many
kids were partying out there and getting
drunk and getting hurt and I saw that
it's a big article on it that they
wanted to you know burn the place down
with the fire department I did talk to
somebody that wanted you know didn't
want to tell me his name
on the fire department that was there
during the time of the fire and he said
you could tell it was the controlled
burn nothing burned around it
he says that's all I'm gonna say there's
trees that are like twice as high as
summer wind it's kind of hard to believe
that lightning struck at twice and
burned it to the ground I believe yeah
sound like they burned it down
yeah keep people out no it's too bad you
know
I highly doubt you know being that it
was in such bad repair you know in ruins
then you know I always thought to ask
the owners you know well if you dug
deeper into that and actually found out
that someone did burn down your house
purposely
I think there'd be a case there but
being that there probably isn't any
insurance to collect off of a house that
was pretty much a done deal I know it
was appeared in the time Life magazine
in 1980 November issue I got a copy I
picked one up off of ebay for five
dollars it's pretty cool issue it's got
Walter Cronkite on the front life and
times of Walter Cronkite and then in the
middle of the book it's got the top 10
most haunted places in the United States
and summer wind is in there so what was
that house like back in the 80s it was
still creepy I mean it's a lot of rooms
just a weird feeling going inside almost
like something was all you watching you
of course the place has history and if a
place has history you're already gonna
walk into the place thinking something's
there right yeah that's true because I
mean like I said even before the hinge
house moved in in the 70s I don't know
if there was really a lot of ghost
stories from the other owners like maybe
in the 50s and 60s because the house was
built in what 1916 something like that
1914 as a fishing lodge where he could
stay the night for $5.00
then 1916 Robert Lamont added on to it
and made it into what you know he would
call the mansion on the summerwine
mansion and he did it with the Chicago
architects Thomas - Madge and Vernon
Watson and they redesigned the fishing
lodge into a mansion yeah and he and him
and his wife claimed that they saw a
ghost there right yep yeah well there
was the maids that came to him and said
oh my god the place is haunted
and he didn't really believe him until
he was sitting down to have dinner and a
ghost walked through the door or some
type of board or any Bulldog
black-powder pistol and shot at it three
times courts missing it it is so yeah
I've seen voter there's pictures online
that nobody took of the bullet holes in
the door the photographs I've seen of it
the interview I think they were it was
from the 80s it looked pretty damn dumpy
the interior and the exterior yeah
definitely um I haven't actually gotten
some pictures through the years from
different people from late 70s where it
looks better I mean it needs a paint job
regardless but the house on the outside
looks better I got pictures of the
inside with the furnace intact the
basement going into the basement so it's
kind of cool what I'm looking forward to
is we got an event coming up on
September 30th out at Summerwind
it's called Wisconsin's biggest well
it's actually called the world's biggest
ghost hunt and we're one of the teams
representing Summerwind
in Wisconsin there's only two teams in
Wisconsin doing this and we're doing it
up at some win but what it is is they're
linking a hundred different teams around
the world all at once we're gonna be
live-streaming from a hundred different
places around the world and we got
picked to do summer wind up there that's
awesome yeah for for a live stream event
yeah so that's on September 30th and
we're like gonna livestream it and that
would be pretty cool do something out
there we had to find a carrier to be
able to have a hot spot out there it's
like in the middle of nowhere yeah
that's true it's like it when when I see
the pictures of it it does really seem
like it's I'm not really sure how far
away from civilization it is because
it's like I keep getting it confused cuz
I'm so used to seeing that episode of a
haunting that was about it
yeah where it looked like it was kinda
by itself but there were other houses
around there's a house like right next
door to the right within I'd say 75
yards and then there's a house probably
under 50 yards down a hill steep hill
with a bunch of woods there but in all
in all the place the pump you know just
those properties are sitting on this
little Peninsula love you know like a
little tiny Bay of West Bay Lake and
then all around that those couple
properties just massive woods going for
miles and miles in every direction so
about Arnold Henshaw we call him a
raccoon man on our program well just
because the actor that played him on a
hot day killed the kids record startle
Henshaw lost his mind
is there any dude do we have any details
on that what what was wrong with them
was it paranoid schizophrenia or he
would he was committed right yeah I'm
not so certain what it was the only
thing I hear is the same thing that
probably everybody else hears is that he
played the organ in his house to all
hours of the night stating that if he
didn't play the organ the ghost would be
mad so they basically said you need to
play the organ and all I hear is he
eventually went crazy and ginger tried
to commit suicide no I got a little bit
of news that's a little bit different
than what you guys actually heard is
Arnold Henshaw was in fact not Arnold
Hinshaw well he was Arnold Hinshaw but
that was his stage name nobody wanted to
know his nobody wanted anybody to know
his real name
his real name was actually Jim Hill h al
l am he'll and the only reason I know
that is because I'm friends with Joshua
of course who knows
April Lynch on April Henshaw was the
girl a little girl at the time that
crawled inside the foundation and found
the corpse in the wall yeah that's right
and I think that's something because
when I was reading like I said I've been
reading kind of recaps of the case
online and I don't think they put that
in the episode did that nobody found a
corpse in the wall no and then they
claimed that they went back later many
years later and it was gone did they
he'll do a static and what that seems
weird like why wouldn't they report it
because I I feel like if you're gonna
live in a house I really don't think I'd
like the thought of a course behind the
wall you know
[Music]
you know was that something that was you
know that they created to add on to it
or was it really there and what they did
go back and was gone but why didn't they
report it to the police with my question
yeah I wouldn't live in a house that I
thought that seemed strange that they
didn't mention it on the episode yeah
yeah some of the good stuff farted out
of the episode I thought maybe that you
said that there was somebody living next
door to the Summerwind mansion for a
long time and he said that they had
stories well what did they tell you they
just said that they came up a bunch of
times for the property and nobody was
there they would see like red eyes and
the dark blinking at them weird to me
which sounds a little bit demonic but
you know that could be anything it could
be their imagination they said that they
would hear weird noises come from the
property late at night you know if they
would walk up the hill and take a look
at it and stuff the guy the guy that I
actually which I'm waiting waiting to
meet him he actually lived next to
Summerwind I'd like to say lived there
in fifties sixties seventies he lived
right next door and he called me up I
should a couple months ago he said that
he has the original shutters to summer
wind and he wants to give them to us so
I thought that was really cool and he
said he's got pictures from back when
the house was in pretty much mint
condition so I'm waiting to see them I
have never seen any pictures anywhere
and I can't find any of what the house
looked like on the inside with when it
wasn't in ruins yeah because every
picture I've seen of the inside of it it
just looks totally wrecked it looks
wrecked and the whole house looks like
it's sagging and drooping it looks like
it looks like all the wood has been
water damaged be nice to see some
pictures where you know maybe there's
furniture in there it looks nice some
people did someone it'd be great if I
could find some picture back when the
Hinshaw is first had it so yeah because
now when they moved in it was it had
still been abandoned it had been
abandoned for quite a while before me
right yeah so they did do some
renovation on it but I think they were
only there for six months right so they
couldn't have gotten all that much done
yeah were they dreaming wait were they
dreaming could this thing be restored
or is that just a pipe dream at the time
at the time at the time I think it could
have been but it would have taken a lot
of work I mean the you know the shutters
were all fall I mean if you look at the
time like magazine in 1980 you know it
was it was pretty pretty poor shape then
but they had it in the 70s so I would
think that it was when I see the
pictures from the 70s
it looks like it's possible to restore
it I mean the the fireplace on the
inside was intact I got some pictures of
the fireplace it looks really nice pool
table inside you know so when they had
they should have at least had some
decency to the house you know other than
maybe needing some minor repairs it's
maybe some paint and stuff to make it
look better but the house looked pretty
decent back in the 70s from the pictures
that I can have yeah because the
pictures that I've seen from the 80s it
looks like that house is getting ready
to fall over and it looks like you
wouldn't be able to safely walk through
it but you said you did then it was
structurally sound yeah it was sound it
just looked terrible on the outside with
your group Fox Valley Ghost Hunters have
you actually done like a formal
investigation on the site yeah we've
actually investigated there many times
probably both I'd have to say about 15
times mom yeah cuz I yeah I thought you
had done several like what what's the
kind of the most significant thing that
you found while you were investigating
this we've captured actually another
team that was with us we bring teams up
there to hang out with us to investigate
with us sometimes because everybody
wants to go there so we brought a team
with us and they investigated and they
captured a shadow figure down where the
basement be by the stone brick
foundation and you could see it clearly
walking from the foundation up towards
the hill they caught it on high eight
camera right now I believe they're
working to get it digitalize so it made
it easier for people to see we've also
seen shadows out there people that have
come to our events have taken pictures
and captured things and their pictures
people in their pictures and like period
clothes I'm standing next to chimney or
you know sitting on one of the steps of
the foundation and they come running up
to us and to show us and it's legit I
mean they don't have time to photoshop
it into
that's a problem with that today so but
some of our investigations have
disembodied voices and ghost box
sessions which we had a Ghost Box
session where a male voice says little
girl dead is your friend and supposedly
there's a little girl up there and we we
talked to her quite a few times we got
one little girl named Susie and one
little girl named Lucy which comes up a
lot in the hauntings what are you that
little girl is then not sure when I
first started doing investigations on
the property and when I used to go there
back in the high school days there was
up in the woods a looks like a burial
site you could see where there's like
these really fancy bricks around in like
a rectangular type setting and then
there was a cross on the top of the at
the very top and it had a name on it and
said Lucy no was it a I'm hoping that
wasn't a dog according to the according
to someone when I talked him back then
one of the families had a daughter that
passed away but yet I can't find it
listed anywhere but you're gonna hear
Lucy come up quite a bit um there's a
bunch of different articles that talk
about a little girl named Lucy that was
buried on the property and you know I
believe that would have been her but I
can't we can't pinpoint who it was we
thought it was maybe Robert Lamont's
wife or daughter and it wasn't either
his wife's name was like Gertrude or
something or something different or
off-the-wall name but we can't find
anybody associated with Lucy other than
the fact that she comes into play in
quite a few articles I tell you what one
of the weirdest aspects of Summerwind at
least the war behind it Raymond claimed
that you could measure out like the
rooms yeah say for instance like the
living room it could measure it out one
time and then the second time he
measured it out the room was bigger than
it was before
that it was constantly changing shape
and size yeah and I think he said to you
that even when he took pictures of the
house like the rooms would look bigger
the house would seem to change size or
the curtains would be there when they
weren't original or he would see the
curtains in the photos when they were
not really there
what do you know about that yes they did
you mentioned that on the episode no
they should have because
that's kind of a strange yeah that's a
pretty interesting possible I had talked
to the current owners and of course they
didn't stay there because it was in
ruins Lillian never stayed on the
property but they stayed near the
property on a trailer near the end of
the driveway and they said at night they
would walk up to the mansion and one
night they're walking up to the mansion
and it was a full moon and they she says
oh my god I've never been so scared in
all my life when we walked up towards a
mansion in the moonlight it looked as
though was alive the mansion was
breathing in and exhaling and breathing
in and exhaling they turned around and
walked back down the mine so wisely the
snedecker case when they said that the
the mattresses were breathing remember
right yeah to be honest that's always
kind of creeped me out like houses with
like different rooms or we you know like
the book House of Leaves which was like
kind of a really popular order several
years ago like in the early 2000s I
think and that was kind of a thing where
you would go in the house and it would
change configuration and like the rooms
would change sizes and they would go
down in the basement and it just kept
going and going and going like when
there was no way it could and so that
was always kind of that was a detail
that always fascinated me about the
summerwine mansion I'm kind of sad that
they didn't mention that on the 2005 a
haunted because that's that's pretty
cool didn't happen and that was
something that Raymond made up that's
that's one time we had two girls on
isolation and earlier we had two girls
on isolation out in the woods you know
probably about 75 yards hundred yards
from us while we were down at the other
end we gave them a walkie-talkie so that
they you know I guess had any issues of
course about five minutes later we hear
them both screaming like crazy so we ran
up there into the woods and this would
be where I saw Lucy you know had
supposedly there was a girl Lucy buried
there that's where we had them sitting
in the woods and we ran up there to see
if they
okay and they were like just terrified
here a raccoon had fallen out of a tree
and landed right next to them but the
weirder part to that is we always have
some a camera on whoever's you know in
isolation so we had a ia camera on there
with night vision on there recording so
I went back over the spot where the
wreck one had fallen off the tree and
just after just before the raccoon falls
on the tree there's a voice that says
I'm gonna push it maybe maybe the guy
that Arnold still looking for because
ginger Hinshaw died in 2013 right yeah
which is actually Jim he'll just that he
just passed away that's why he was we
were able to get his real name because
now I guess he just passed away I would
probably say a couple months ago um I
least according to a poll or at least
according to Josh one stuff said that
his real name was actually Jim Hill and
he was actually never married to show up
but they had the daughter April okay
now they all the I don't remember if the
if the episode had this but all the
written all the breakdowns of it online
say that they had six children different
merits although I think that most of
them were gingers right I don't think
that yeah yeah because I think April was
the only one that was that was there's
maybe no yeah maybe because the only one
that I know that Joshua is in contact
with is April so yeah and I think she
was the only one that was on the show
right or no there were two of them on
the show two of the daughters yeah I
think we're intervened I just don't
remember the other ones name the story
then this story that we get is that
Arnold have you called him Jim he'll he
skipped the rest of his life in a mental
institution or is that just legend I'm
still trying to get a chance to talk to
April too so that's something maybe
Joshua can answer yeah we should yeah
always always wondering what the deal
was with that because remember in in the
hauntings episode gingers leaving with
the kids and she leaves Arnold in some
and he's there and he leaves the next
day and I was thinking to myself back
then I don't know man what would that be
like to stay in that a house by yourself
that's what I'm thinking maybe it just
sent him over the edge
yeah okay we're gonna stop here and take
a short break just run a couple of
commercials and then after the break we
will come back and resume our discussion
with Craig Naren we'll be back in just a
couple minutes
[Music]
[Music]
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour to spare check out
our new list channel 13 o'clock in
minutes all the fun creepy topics of the
main podcast but an easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
yeah I I had the feeling that the first
part of the story is closer to the truth
in the second part of the story I think
Raymond kind of got involved in there
and tried to capitalize on it and turn
it into a haunted house because he
wanted to put a concession stand yeah so
you know he with that book the whole car
effect you know I read it and like I
said there's a lot of stuff that's hard
to swallow on there um so like you said
I think he wanted to make some money and
you know that book you know summer wind
was a big deal back then you can't even
find those books they did a reprinting
of it and I got a reprinting in Raymond
Vaughn Gobert son signed it for me so I
thought that was awesome but it's still
hard to believe some of that stuff in
that book really happened well what kind
of stuff is in the Carver effect they
say that that book is really hard to get
ahold of how'd you find it um I got one
from his son Raymond bond Beaubourg jr.
actually he autographed it for me and
gave it to me at one of my
investigations up there so everyone
showed up on ebay how much you think
that'd be worth nice I see him on ebay
every once in a while going from three
to five hundred dollars a couple people
ask me for mine and I'm like Oh mine's
autographed so everything from the car
starting on fire to a lot of stuff where
people left the property they wouldn't
work on things the repairmen
the repairmen that says even if you read
about when they were trying to fix up
the house that the electricians and
everything would see [ __ ] and I want to
stay there and left the property Wow I
don't know I was an electrician I don't
think I would scare me away you know I'd
have to be something it'd have to be
something really you know severe or
something to happen to scare me off the
property rather than just you know
whispers or something you know
ginger reported the same thing according
to the haunting episode and I was
thinking at the time I was on that must
be a pretty creepy place and then I saw
photographs of
of the place from the 80s and I was
thinking probably would happen as the
contractors show up and go man this
can't be repaired they're like you know
we don't want to get involved in
something this big you know this house
is on its way out it's gonna be
condemned and that's what I thought
well you know I wasn't there either way
it's an interesting story whether it's
the parts of it was fabricated or you
know whatever so tell us about how you
got started on the summer wood
restoration project and how far you're
gonna get on what what you're planning
to do when you get the house rebuilt all
that kind of stuff
how we got started was you know I have a
love for the property everybody around
us has a love for the property people
call me from all over the world saying
you know for some reason I'm drawn to
this place called summer wind we want to
go there I got people that done papers
on it you know like school papers and
books on it all the way over and I
believe India and other places like that
so you know what the owners now one of
the main owners heard their names are
Harold live Babs Tracy she just had a
heart attack she's not heart attack she
had a stroke but close enough and she's
having problems talking when I call her
she's all happy but she can't speak it
so we're hoping that we would like to
try to get it rebuilt before something
worse happens to her because that was
her dream so in lieu of that our plans
to rebuild the mansion you know thanks
to Joshua as well because he got us the
original blueprint blueprints for the
property dated back to 1916 or 1920 the
original blueprints all the way down to
the skeleton key that went in the door
so and they were going for like $50,000
online at one point and he got him for
3,000 made me a copy and sent him to me
he's got one of the original copies of
course but it's easy enough to we had a
couple people look at it they were
talking at least $500,000 to start the
project you know to actually have
something there
you it wouldn't be exposed to the
elements and stuff I've got people that
one on pound nails I got people that
want to you know they'll do everything
for free I got people mason people that
said they'll come up there and do it for
free just to get their name on something
to say that they helped to rebuild the
mansion I'm also working with if you
know where this guy is um you know Jeff
Bellinger is a lander uh-huh he is the
producer of the ghost hunter show and
the paranormal lockdown Ghost Adventures
homage haunting probably about sixty
other different paranormal things
throughout the years he's written books
and stuff he actually got ahold of me he
was looking for a producer or another
person to back the Summerwind project
for us because he says it's something
that's never been done
no one's ever rebuilt a haunted mansion
back up to its former glory so it's a
really interesting project but it's also
a project that's a little bit risky
because it's never been done so he's
working on helping us find someone right
now we're probably about halfway there
with the funds so all's it takes is one
person with the love of haunted mansions
to say hey I'll do this and our whole
thing was to make it into a
bed-and-breakfast something where the
public could come and enjoy the property
rather than now trespassing on the
property and stealing bricks and other
things off the property which is
supposably if you steal something from
the property you're cursed and I've had
people come up to me and say bad things
has happened to them after they took
stuff from the property yeah I've heard
that about some and some other haunted
locations you can't take any bigger so
how do people get in contact with you in
order to think contributors or to get
involved we got a bunch of different
sites now we got some Irwin restorations
this idea on Facebook they can contact
us for that they can contact me through
Fox Valley Ghost Hunters calm or Fox
Valley Ghost Hunters on Facebook I know
just started another page on Facebook
called um Wisconsin's most haunted
places and we got a lot of people
joining that and our my phone number and
my emails are always on all them on
how to get a hold of us we gotta go fund
me out there - I forgot exactly uh where
it's at I know what's under some Erwin
somewhere but I haven't gone to it
lately it's not doing so well those go
fund me is don't seem to do so well on
certain aspects but yet they do well if
someone's looking for a parachute
suddenly all these people are getting
all this money I'll it's just weird I
have never understood like why some
GoFundMe is like because I don't see the
difference for now that sounds cool that
doesn't sound as cool but it has like
three times the amount of money someone
looking for because they couldn't afford
shoes and holes and there's get like
$20,000 and I'm like wait a minute this
is just right the old plated shoes so
you've been doing Fox Valley ghost
hunters for how long probably about ten
years seven years with the team in ten
years altogether cut okay and you've
written a book called Wisconsin it all
yep Wisconsin I'm also got number I'm
working on my second book Wisconsin's
most haunted volume to which I'm hoping
they haven't done the end of this month
so and then there'll be a third book on
all the investigations that we've done
in different places we've gone for all
the places out of state
tell us about some some other
investigations you've been on either
around Wisconsin or other place I know
you've I think you've been to the
Villisca ax Murder House and stuff like
that the first time we went we had some
awesome interaction we just went a
couple I probably bout six seven months
ago
we went again it was really cold it was
in fact snowing and it was just it's
just hard to get comfortable in there
and investigate but we two of our girls
on our team saw a big bright light that
kind of faded on the top of the wall and
they said it looked like a star falling
I quote I didn't see it so but they were
so scared I had some cool stuff happen
while we're there some voices and stuff
but one of the best places by far that I
will tell if anybody ever wants to go
and they should go is for our farr a are
haunted school in iowa is by far the
most haunted place we've ever
encountered I've been there 15 times at
least we did I start in US Cellular
commercial store in the middle of
anywhere series where they did the
Haunted thing last October so I we are
wearing three different US seller
commercials and one of them was from
Farrar and every time we go to Farrar we
had an event there just a couple months
ago we sold all everybody from Wisconsin
all our followers came up there and
investigated with us and stayed for two
nights there's an auditorium up there
like a gym in the old school not an
auditorium at the stage in the school
and we always sleep in that section of
the building
every time we sleep there every night
now that we've slept there you hear loud
footsteps of little kids or I would say
probably possibly kids running into the
room and then running back out we've
caught it on audio it's just it's an
insane place by far the most haunted
place that we've investigated and
continue to investigate wow that's
really cool yeah another cool thing from
Farrar itself was with the footsteps
that run into the room and just make
your hair stand up and then we'd had an
investigation there last year and we had
air mattresses in that room and not
probably like an hour after we've been
there we're all sitting in that stage
area upstairs in the room and all son
something runs into the room runs right
across one of our investigators air
mattresses to the point where the air
mattress kind of bounced up into the air
a little bit and he goes what the [ __ ]
was that he was like something just ran
across my bed and you know I didn't
actually heard I only heard a couple
footsteps but when I played it back on
audio you could clearly hear something
running in and we caught on video where
the air mattress jumps up a little bit
but at the same time that your mattress
is jumping up you could clearly see an
apparition of like some type of floating
debris come into the room and then come
back out of the room I actually it took
me a while to view that to actually see
that on video but I'm like that's that's
not dust that's that's like a cloud of
like mist running into the room and then
running back out of the room at the same
time we heard the footsteps in the air
mattress jumps up in the air we're
that's pretty well
just some crazy voices they're just EVPs
from the place we've captured so many
EVPs for the years some saying like
Lucas can't see me or you know one of
our investigators sneezed in the hallway
and a little girl rules bless you so
since we were talking about a haunting
at about the Summerwind episode
everything like that do you generally
like paranormal shows that are on now or
do you think they're kind of detrimental
to ghost hunting investigations I mean
do you think people get kind of a
misperception yeah I would say people
definitely get misled by the shows a lot
of them that come on our investigations
you know think that they're gonna see
stuff and things are gonna fly across
the room chairs are gonna move doors are
gonna slam and you know that's like the
golden opportunity if something like
that happens and you know I've seen on
my investigations throughout you know
the 10 years 7 years that we've been
doing it as a team so we've captured two
people in in some pictures we captured a
little girl Lima captured another little
girl drinking out of a drinking fountain
in an old church but to actually capture
we've only seen maybe two channels move
on one shadow of our own and another
shadow caught by another team moving
around actually captured it on camera so
the stuff that happens on the TV shows
seems to happen every couple seconds on
the TV shows and yeah I think it
misleads the people who think that you
know you walk into a haunted place and
you're just gonna see stuff Bam Bam Bam
yeah this is just gonna be flying around
everywhere because I mean honestly we
you know I've written books with Steve
Mehra's to British parapsychologists and
he's been investigating cases for more
than 30 years and he said you know it's
really really rare for anything to
happen it's like sometimes you have to
like sit there for days and weeks
sometimes nothing happens sometimes just
some little minor thing happens and it
does seem like you know I know that the
TV shows are just entertainment and you
know
if nothing happened on the show nobody
would watch it yeah would be a little
bit more accurate that possibly they're
getting what they're hearing as the EVPs
but all the other stuff that's happening
you know all things moving around you
know half the time when we're on
investigations we'll hear a lot of stuff
move everything slides across the floor
but we never have a camera in the area
where we hear it so we can't capture it
yeah I do feel like stuff like that
tends to happen outside of the range of
the cameras and then they're constantly
forcing ghosts and poltergeists into the
same phenomenon when history will show
over and over again that those are two
separate phenomena Pokhara Gallo ultra
Geist has haunted children basically
which is only some people would call it
r SP k which is recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis and Jenny wrote a book
about my episode my family because you
know I had I was the center of a
poltergeist a outbreak yeah it only
lasted two weeks and if I relapse every
now and then Jenny's seen it some
friends but now it's it's weak it's
compared to what it was and I was kid of
course yeah I've never actually
investigated a a poltergeist activity um
all this stuff that you kind of see on
the shows is that kind of what happens
Werth weird things like love upper
knocks loud bangs yeah movement of
objects and it's nothing it kind of
starts off slowly and it'll ramp up
it'll ramp up to a crescendo during the
evening and then it'll kind of trail
back off again usually the whole a whole
poltergeist episode really only lasts
about a week or two that's that's the
common one that's a common length the
biggest case probably would have been
the Enfield poltergeist that lasted 18
months and seen by police newspaper
reporters but I tell the whole story in
math Mountain poltergeist and GZ Jenny
wrote a really good book called the
unseen hand which has over a hundred
poltergeist cases in it some people have
almost called it a source book SBR loved
it yeah
I mean I generally stay I stayed away
from stuff that was more haunting based
I mean there was like they said you know
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of crossover in that area where
sometimes poltergeist activity can seem
like a haunting it yeah I mean it just
seemed like a hybrid between the two
yeah and you know we've definitely read
about some that are like that have you
ever had anything like that where you
say I mean do you do think they're two
separate phenomena that they're caused
by two separate things
[Music]
the poltergeist or whatever cases of
where they say it's caused by you know a
young child in the house and you know
wasn't always the case I haven't seen
anything I'd be you know I'm interested
in that aspect of it you know I got
people that call me all the time and say
you know I think I got a poltergeist
miles I think so
and all this stuff's moving around but
we go there and nothing ever happens you
know it's like they're hiding when a new
person is introduced into the
environment it kind of puts performance
anxiety on the poltergeist focus so
something you know and sometimes it's
kind of like the fear of looking like an
idiot puts its anxiety on you know on
the focus that's that's good you know I
guess it's a good way to describe it
yeah you guys going back to the summer
way mansion so you're doing the world's
largest ghost hunt and that's on
September 30th and now people can
participate in that right if they want
to yeah blue so I know it's the world's
biggest ghost hunt calm and you can see
I don't know if they probably won't have
a link up to you know how to view it
until closer to that date they got their
doing not they got base area and with
the booth brothers and stuff over in
Kentucky is there like their base camp
and then they also got people on the
Queen Mary over in the California oh
right yeah this has been a fantastic
show Craig we'd love to have you back on
yet
yeah cuz yeah this is really fascinating
and like you know you said you're
halfway to rebuilding the mansion and so
hopefully the people here sit here you
on the show and stuff like that and
going because I would actually really
like to see that house rebuilt yeah
to how it because I you know I've seen
like a couple old fashioned photos of it
maybe from the 20s and 30s yeah we're
kind of you know you can kind of see
what it sort of looked like but I I'm
really curious to see it was a mixture
of a lot of different styles definitely
interesting to see it rebuilt I know I
got people call me now saying if you're
gonna turn it into a bed-and-breakfast
we want to get on the list to stay there
so I got like a list of people I want to
stay at a place that's not even built
yet so yeah I said we should really stay
there how big was the place really it's
hard to get an idea of how big it was
you know I read stories where had 32
rooms but are we would say four rooms
are we counting did they count closet
sets rooms because I mean it was big in
in that that periods as being a mansion
but in today's aspect of a mansion I
think there's houses that are much
bigger right yeah it seems even from the
pictures I'm like I don't know if I'd
call that a mansion nowadays yeah it's
bigger than average but not yeah we live
in a place that has huge McMansions just
right at the road yeah I guess if you
bring me back on the show I got so many
other stories to tell from all of our
other investigations creepy ones just
crazy ones yeah that would be awesome
the show's been fantastic cool is there
anything else that you wanted to plug
yeah just plug your book in plug this
your group just basically that watch for
my new book Wisconsin's Most Wanted vol
2 if you don't have the first one it is
on Amazon and stuff I actually got
autographed copies I've seen out on eBay
where I autographed them that they're
going for like $185
and also people if I'll put links in all
the description everything to Fox Valley
ghost centers you guys will come out and
do investigations if any
one in the areas having problems with
the haunting correct yeah yep we do
Wisconsin and the European Michigan we
covered the whole state of Wisconsin in
Michigan
okay that's cool and so like I said I'll
put links to your book I'll put links to
Fox Valley Ghost Hunters and I'm gonna
put links to some Erwin restoration
society so you can go so everyone can go
and check out what's going on with them
if you want to contribute or anything
like that yeah
our fans are gonna love this show they
love summer women yes that was one of
our most popular episodes yes we did and
actually on that show we were kind of
talking about summer and terrible we're
mostly talking about the episode of a
haunting because we do you know kind of
reviews of episodes of a haunting every
day and that was actually our favorite
one yeah it's definitely the spookiest
yeah you know the earlier the earlier
seasons over Achtung we're better yeah
haunting kind of went out kind of went
downhill after about what four seasons
yeah to me it kind of seemed like well
they started going a little crazy yeah
it started be little to go over a little
bit over the top yeah I liked the
earlier one ski they were kind of
low-key which and like I said it's it's
kind of interesting because the
Summerwind episode they left out some
really yeah interesting interesting
stuff they left out like the room
changing thing they left out the car
Catching Fire they left the body yeah
they left it that seems I was like
Austin's the three things you would want
to put in there you think so thank you
very much for being on our show and we
will definitely have to have you back so
you can talk about some more hauntings
in Wisconsin yeah and thank you and that
was our interview with Craig Naren of
Fox Valley ghost hunters and this summer
wind restoration Society please check
out the websites and the Facebook pages
of both those groups I will provide
links below but all you really have to
do is just search Fox Valley ghost
hunters search Craig Nehring or search
the Summerwind restoration society and
you will find all of those things
also check out Craig's book Wisconsin's
most haunted and keep an eye out for the
second volume which should be out very
soon and if you're a fan of the 13
o'clock podcast please remember to like
follow share and subscribe on all our
various social media sites also remember
to check out our list channel 13 o'clock
in minutes please subscribe to that
check out our t-shirts at
komm / 13 o'clock also if you're into
horror and want to read some movie
reviews and stuff like that check out my
horror blog at goddess of hellfire calm
I just put a couple new movie reviews up
there so be sure to check those out I
think I did the shrine and a couple
other ones and also please support us on
patreon and get cool free [ __ ] and
secret stuff that nobody else gets so
shh don't tell anybody but there's
really cool stuff on there so until next
time keep looking for that raccoon and
tune in next Tuesday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you